انا اولا ما يتعلق بباخمت ليس فقط لم تاتي
فقط تصريحات قائد مجموعات وانما ايضا من
اداره اقليم دانيسك
المسؤولون هناك صرحوا بان القوات الروسيه
تمكنت من احكام الحصار حول ضخمه وقطعت
عمليا الامدادات الامداد لمجموعات القوات
الاوكرانيه المتواجده في المدينه
وايضا اصبحت المساله بحسب تقديرات قياده
المعارك هناك يمكن ان السيطره على ضخمه
خلال ساعات قليله بالامس بريجوجن زعيم
فاجنر نشر فيديوهات عليها صور
لمقاتلي في وسط المدينه واليوم وجه رساله
مصوره الى زيلينسكي طلبه فيه بالموافقه
على انسحاب قواته من باخ السماح لهم بل
وكان ايضا في هذه الرساله المتصوره ثلاث
جنود اوكرانيا يطلبون من الرئيس الاوكراني
السماح لهم بالعوده الى ديارهم هناك
معلومات ايضا تسربت يعني او نشرت بالاحرى
نشرها قائد للقوات الاوكرانيه مديار
المتواجده في ضخمه بان وحدته تلقت بالفعل
اوامر بالانسحاب بعد نحو ثلاثه شهور من
المعارك الى مواقع اخرى لمواصله القتال ضد
القوات الروسيه لذلك الوضع في يبدو انه
يقترب من الحسم النهائي بحسب تقديرات
الروسيه
والتصريحات التي صدرتها من الجانب الروسي
او من الجانب الاوكراني اذكر بان ايضا
نواب برلمان اعضاء لجنه الامن البرلمان
الاوكراني تحدثوا عن ان الوضع في سيء
ويستوجب سحب القوات من هناك
مازلنا عباس مراسلنا من موسكو شكرا جزيلا
لك